[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen den sallys
welt und in aller welt ich habe mir
lange überlegt ob ich dieses jahr eine
weihnachtskarte mache oder doch etwas
anderes und ich habe schon ein paar
weihnachten auf meinem kanal und auch
bei lidl habe ich eine ganz ganz tolle
weihnachtskarte gemacht die könnt ihr
euch gerne mal anschauen haben uns
überlegt zu weihnachten machen wir doch
was ganz spezielles oder ella ja und
zwar haben wir hier diese kekse plus
vorbereitet xix das sind praktisch pop
sickels also wie auch cake pops am stiel
kuchen am stiel und das ganze könnt ihr
entweder so machen dass ihr den kuchen
bereit in die form backt oder verwendet
ein kuchen wie zum beispiel ein
gugelhupf marmorkuchen blechkuchen
zerkrümelt den mit einer tollen creme
und könnte auch so eine schöne art
resteverwertung machen auch wenn der
kuchen vielleicht schon mal zwei drei
tage alt ist
ich hatte die von einem anderen kuchen
übrig und hab das einfach hier verwendet
ganz schön schlau oder
ja so viel hat sich übrig oder ihr könnt
sagen ihr packt einfach einen frischen
blechkuchen dafür ich zeige euch jetzt
gleich mal einen kuchen der wirklich
super einfach ist das ist nämlich so
eine art becher kuchen und das ganze ist
ein all in one teig das heißt ich kann
die zutaten einmal abwägen und dann wird
wirklich alles nur noch zusammen gemixt
und fertig und dann habe ich jetzt hier
vier verschiedene dekos gemacht und ich
finde dass diese cache sickels auch eine
ganz ganz tolle geschenkidee sind ihr
könnt die nämlich hübsch verpacken und
auch an weihnachten verschenken vor
allem wenn man jetzt gerade seine
liebsten vielleicht auch nicht sehen
kann weil es einfach die umstände nicht
irgendwie anders zu lassen und dann
haben wir eben hier eine schöne
dekoration
sehr gut er darf ihre eigenen cache
sickels machen ich zeige euch kurz die
zutaten und dann geht es direkt ans teig
banken
für den teig nämlich 4 200 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt und salz 200 gramm
joghurt oder schmand 200 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 100 gramm gemahlene
haselnüsse etwas zimt und 300 gramm mehl
+15 teelöffel backpulver oder verwendet
einfach das webmail da ist es backpulver
schon dabei den ofen habe ich schon
vorgeheizt auf 170 grad ober unterhitze
ich habe ich meinen backblech das habe
ich einfach mit dem bug rahmen
ausgestattet ihr könnt jede andere
backform verwenden die ihr wollt denn
der kuchen wird später sowieso
zerkrümelt und jetzt heißt einfach alles
kommt in eine schüssel und wird einfach
kurz verrührt all-in-one teig
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es echte einfachste teil
in der backform backte jetzt auch etwa
in 25 bis 30 minuten fertig und die zeit
kann ich jetzt schon mal nutzen und
direkt noch die creme zu bereiten
[Musik]
der kuchen gebacken und abgekühlt jetzt
geht's direkt an die creme ich mache
jetzt ihr eine frischkäse buttercreme
ihr könnt aber auch jeder andere creme
verwenden die ihr gerne möglich wäre
jetzt diese butter frischkäse creme weil
die dann auch schön fest wird die
schmeckt sehr gut schmeckt leicht die
schmeckt echt nicht so fertig wie man
sich das vielleicht vorstellt die ist
echt richtig gut und ihr könnt ihr auch
gerne verfeinern wenn ihr möchtet also
die basis sind praktisch 200 gramm
reiche butter 150 gramm puderzucker 200
gramm frischkäse im doppel raum stufe
und vanille extrakt und ich habe hier
den puderzucker ein bisschen reduziert
normalerweise nämlich immer alles eins
zu eins zu eins also 200 von allem das
kann ich mir auch immer ganz gut merken
bruder zugabe 10 reduziert weil er das
ganze sowieso später noch überzogen wird
mit kuvertüre und allem dass es halt
nicht so süß ist genau und jetzt nehmt
ihr einfach die weiche butter mit dem
puderzucker für rotes kurz für 23
minuten
[Musik]
sie sehen später so aus
danke jetzt liegt nämlich alles auf
eigentlich ist sarah die bäckerin hier
bitteschön
so und was kommt dann rein
okay was ist okay
nein das ist
dann kommt hier jetzt wandel extrakt und
frischkäse dazu
dann kurz vor rühren also was ihr
wirklich jetzt machen könnt ihr könnt
noch mehr zimt dazu geben ihr können
haselnuss likör dazu geben wenn jetzt
keine kinder mitessen ihr könnt
cranberries dazu geben alles was er
praktisch im geschmack ich drin haben
wollt ihr könnt auch ich meine jetzt
sehr weihnachtsbäckerei schon fast
vorbei ihr könnt eine komplette
resteverwertung machen und alle eure
vorratsdosen leer machen wo zum beispiel
noch getrocknetes obst drin ist
getrocknete früchte nüsse
zimt zucker egal alles haut einfach
alles rein denn cake pops oder so kickl
sind eigentlich echt immer eine tolle
resteverwertung da könnte alles rein
machen es schmeckt immer gut recht so
[Musik]
ich nehme es mal einen teil der creme
raus denn manchmal brauchen wir
tatsächlich bisschen mehr oder ein
bisschen weniger aber so über die hälfte
lasse ich da drin und jetzt nehmen die
im prinzip einfach nur euren kuchen und
wie gesagt ihr könnt da auch einen
übriggebliebenen mama kuchen kekse haut
alles mit rein alles was noch gut ist
ich kenne dort theoretisch so eine
rohrbombe mexikos machen also einfach
oben mit
ran.de jetzt einfach schon mal
handschuhe an weil ich nicht die masse
gleich ihr können mit der küchenmaschine
machen das geht auch nicht zum flach
hörer aber ich mache das jetzt so dann
sehe ich auch immer wie die konsistenz
ist
als einfach den kuchen nehmen
und da rein zerbröseln und alles gut
durchmischen
[Musik]
gottes riecht so gut mit den haselnüssen
da drin ich lieb' haselnuss kurven
man hat auch eine größere schüssel
nehmen können also aber es drückt sich
gleich zusammen
so
die besten reste zum weihnachtsfest
können alle rechte reinraum jetzt schön
vermischen am ende solltet ihr eine
konsistenz haben die wie eigentlich
knete ist nicht so ganz wie knete schon
ein bisschen kuchen artig aber die
sollte schön zusammen kleben was ihr
auch sehr gut passt oder espresso oder
so dazugeben und mokka das schmeckt auch
richtig gut so kriegt er dann auch noch
mal schön geschmack mit rein
und es nämlich einfach noch so viel
creme das wirklich die konsistenz passt
ich habe jetzt hier diese eis förmchen
und zwar sind die aus silikon ihr wisst
ich mag nicht so gerne in silikon oder
eigentlich gar nicht aber ich verwende
immer ganz gerne zum formen für zum
beispiel auch mal weglässt örtchen oder
für andere törtchen und tat und hier
diese eis förmchen darin könnt ihr ganz
ganz tolles zubereiten oder eben kickers
und hier kommt dann praktisch diese teig
wasser rein
und das ist dann rechtlich ein cache pop
aber eben in eiform
da rein drücken
und dann nehmt ihr euch
eine tankkarte
und könnte wirklich so flach drüber
gehen
du kannst doch noch was fehlt nur kurz
aber nach drücken
und wer dich
unternehmt ihr euch so ein holzstiel der
kommt nämlich hier unten rein
und ich setze die dann immer ganz gerne
auf meine alu blech weil die alle bleche
einfach bei mir zumindest ganz gut ins
gefrierfach passen falls ihr euch nicht
reinpassen dann nehmt ihr die und stellt
sie einfach ins gefrierfach denn die
kickl sollten auf jeden fall einfrieren
damit diese später aus der form
rausnehmen kann und dann in kuba tiere
tauchen kann und ich zeige euch gleich
wie ich die wirklich komplett
platzsparend verstauen aber jetzt heißt
erstmal auffüllen
[Musik]
kupfer zum auskratzen vom schlüssel
nehme ich immer bei der teig hatte ich
das ja ich meine lieblings zeit hatte
die so flexibel aber trotzdem fest und
dann nehme ich immer hier dieser runde
seite weil da kann ich wirklich schön in
die schüssel rein und einmal komplett
alles auskratzen
obwohl es oft so aussieht als wäre die
schlüssel schon leer aber kommt man hier
fast noch mal ein ganzer kickl da mache
ich jetzt ein paar mini ist noch da raus
und dann nehme ich aber die glatte seite
und das ist hier nämlich jetzt besonders
wichtig weil die glatte seite einfach
eine längere glatte seite hat und die
nehmt ihr jetzt um jede cache sickels
abzuziehen also hier habt ihr die form
gefüllt dann setze ich in der mitte an
sie einmal nach oben weg
und dann einmal nach unten
und dann ist die form perfekt und ich
kann den überschuss dann wieder nehmen
für die nächsten förmchen
habe schon gedacht jetzt haben wir mal
nach schrift jetzt passt sie perfekt
rein ich dachte ich habe jetzt echt so
ein kleines kügelchen übrig und kann es
echt mal endlich naschen jetzt passt es
perfekt in zwei reihen so
und jetzt kann ich hier die förmchen
manchmal mache ich
brauche hier für kleine stille da haben
wir noch zu klein
jetzt habe ich hier praktisch zwei
bleche liegt dazwischen backpapier oder
back folie dann könnte es nämlich direkt
übereinander stapeln und so einfach
einfrieren bis sie komplett gefroren
sind denn dann geht es weiter mit der
dekoration und das ist der richtig
schöne party
[Musik]
jetzt geht's an dem spaßigen thailand
dekorieren dafür verwende ich jetzt
kuvertüre und ich habe jetzt hier einmal
letzter peter kuvertüre damit werde ich
jetzt direkt starten ich habe bei der
zar peter kuvertüre jetzt einfach schon
mal zwei drittel über dem warmen
wasserbad geschmolzen somit wird die
kuvertüre erwärmt und dann eben diese
vom wasserbad herunter oder ihr könnt es
auch in der mikrowelle zubereiten nimmt
sie aus der mikrowelle raus und könnte
das restliche drittel kuvertüre
einrühren und somit die kuvertüre wieder
herunter temperieren also herunterkühlen
und ich habe jetzt hier die kuvertüre
schon fertig dass musik halt leider eine
relativ große menge sein muss ich sagen
denn ich muss er diese cache sickels
auch eintauchen können sowie bei den
sch'tis cache sticks genau was immer
ganz wichtig ist macht auf jeden fall
mit einer tankkarte so eine kleine probe
und wenn ihr die tankkarte eingetaucht
habt und die zieht dann innerhalb von
einer minute schön an und wird glänzend
ist die kurve perfekt ansonsten wenn sie
zu lange noch glänzt und ich fest wird
ist sie zu warm und wenn es um grauen
schleier bekommt dann ist sie einfach
nicht perfekt temperiert und
kristallisiert da versuchte es einfach
noch mal und noch mal kuvertüre sticks
beziehungsweise diese chris wir halten
pellets wird dazu also diese kleinen
kuvertüre chips genau die jobs die sind
so bereits jetzt habe ich fünf
verschiedenen namen kraft die
im duden couture ist leichter london ja
alles gut ok ich arbeite mich jetzt so
ein bisschen einzelnen voran das heißt
ich nehme nur ein paar dieser kuchen
hier raus und der rest es noch im
gefrierfach ich könnte jetzt nämlich
hier ganz gut raus lösen
also einmal die silikon vom lösen dann
mit dem stiel hier absetzen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch ein bisschen weiße
kuvertüre die fülle ich in einen
spritzbeutel damit wird es gleich noch
schön dekoriert und bei der deko da
könnt ihr euch wirklich frei austoben
ich werde jetzt gleich ein paar schöne
edle
sticks machen aber dann könnt ihr auch
so ein paar rentiere zum beispiel machen
was auch gerade für kinder ganz süß ist
ja da kann man sich wirklich bisschen
austoben
so
nehme ich jetzt so ein mini spritzbeutel
und verschließt den meist einfach gern
mit seinem clip
dann muss ich das nicht zwirbeln
und jetzt geht es eigentlich los ich
habe unter der kuvertüre immer gerne
diese universal untersetzer weil meine
arbeitsplatte einfach sehr kalt ist und
die kuvertüre sonst so schnell fest
werden würde und was ich auch habe ich
hab den heißluft führen ihr könnt aber
auch immer ein warmes wasserbad noch
beiseite stellen und wenn die kuvertüre
mal zu sehr abkühlt einfach nochmal
erwerben oder aufs wasser bat stellen
und genau da könnte es so schön arbeiten
weil wir sind hier nicht in der
konditorei und haben leider keine
temporär maschine da hat man wirklich
den ganzen tag temperierte kuvertüre und
kann darauf zurückgreifen aber kommen
irgendwann mal keiner träumen steht
wahrscheinlich hier so ein schokobrunnen
naja mal gucken ich glaube erinnert ok
deco nummer eins ich werde das jetzt
eintauchen und macht dann mit der weißen
kuvertüre so kleine
streifen drauf und wenn das gefäß hier
nicht tief genug ist dann könnt ihr ein
höheres gefäß nehmen oder ein glas
spritzbeutel ständig gibt es jetzt hier
einmal
taucht ein und ich sehe schon okay ich
bin ein anderes gefäß gleich nehmen das
nicht tief genug
und dann abtropfen lassen muss schon
sagen dass sie zur business wie der
warnung werbung schon ja
[Musik]
dann gebe ich hier so ein paar
glitzersteinchen drauf
machte sie doch schön aus
[Musik]
es ist auch das jetzt hier ein in so
einem super glas in vesser doppelglas
geht es natürlich viel viel besser
[Musik]
so bei unserer grad ziemlich viel los
kinder rein und raus jetzt den ball im
hof und spielen und jetzt kann ich hier
in ruhe die xxix fertig machen genau
abtropfen lassen und
die weiße kuvertüre oder karamell
kuvertüre wird auch super passen könnte
dann so ein bisschen drüber laufen
lassen und dann diese gold sterne das
ist echt perfekt das sieht so schön aus
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich noch süße kleine
rentiere dafür brauche ich ein paar
salzbrezeln zucker augen und kleine
smarties also diese schokolinsen ich
habe sie jetzt nicht in rohr ich habe
sehr große aber meine ich finde rosa
passt bei mir ganz gut beim orientieren
was jetzt machen werde die brezeln sind
relativ groß ihr könnt jetzt einmal
halbieren
und damit jetzt auch schön werden tauche
ich die importeure
und legt sich hier aber auf dem
backpapier da ist so ein akku patch
herunter und wird es nämlich ganz
schnell erkannt und ich kann sie dann
gleich weiter verwenden direkt für die
deko und
einfach eintauchen
frischen und staat ablegen
aber es gibt auch wenn ihr euch die
arbeit nicht machen weil es gibt schon
salzbrezeln die mit kuvertüre oder mit
schokolade ummantelt sind
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier
wieder die premium ausstattung der jungs
hat mir hier ein gestell gewalt zu
öffnen
ihr könnt ja auch an den kühlschrank
oder irgendwie die kinder das ganze so
bisschen halten lassen bis das halt ab
tropft ob ich mache das jetzt hier
online gestellt
ich hoffe dass rücksturz not die klammer
bombenfest
man mache ich nämlich vier stück und
kann dann gleich
weitermachen
richtig gut wenn ich selbst hatte direkt
ab weil wenig direkt absätze bekommt so
einen fuß unten also man muss es schon
so ein bisschen halten so bissle bis es
halt abtropfen
durch tauschen
[Musik]
ich habe die jetzt antrocknen lassen
damit gleich die dekoration nicht
herunterfällt also nicht davon schwimmt
und ihr könnt ja dann einfach ein pinsel
nehmen oder einen löffel zahnstocher was
auch immer und gerade so punktuell die
schokolade auftragen und alles drauf
machen also das regt ihr bekommt jetzt
keinen mund
schon mal ganz gut man redet nicht
zwei zucker augen und die nase
und dann wird es auch schön fest und das
geweih außen das finde ich süß die tabs
geweiht
werden sich noch bis zum
mit lebensmittel farbpulver in gold mit
einem trockenen pinsel
[Musik]
was so bei mir am meisten zeit nimmt ist
dass ich halt immer gleich mit zwei drei
kuvertüre sorten arbeite wenn man
nämlich nur einer hat hat man diesen
tempel prozess nur einmal aber ich finde
so hat man immer eine schöne vielfalt dh
die zar peter kexel sind fertig jetzt
nehme ich hier noch dieser karamell
schokolade und die ist aus ganz
natürliche art und war oder auf ganz
natürliche art und weise hat die diesen
karamell geschmack da wird nämlich
einfach der zucker karamellisiert und
daraus wird eben weiß schokolade gemacht
und dann ist die sacramento lade und die
habe ich jetzt hier auch schon fertig
und werde jetzt hierfür noch diese
streut dekore verwenden das sind auch
hier also diese flakes und diese top box
ich habe ich noch diesen crash in gold
das ist so ein amaretto bittermandel
krampf das auch sehr lecker und dann
gucke ich einfach wichtig jetzt aus der
kurier
[Musik]
ich meine es macht schon sinn so was als
2 zu machen ihn wirklich
der eine punkt 1 der andere dekoriert
der andere kommt auf den 23 der andere
breiteres vorbei 4 aber man kann sie
allein machen will muss sich also
bislang mein gott es geht anders
[Musik]
jetzt noch die vierte dekoration dafür
habe ich jetzt wieder die karamell
sticks nehmen dann die kuvertüre ich
möchte so eine art lichterkette machen
ich probiere es funktioniert also so ein
bisschen im einen streifen
[Musik]
und da dann
perlen drin so ein bisschen gezielter
[Musik]
ich glaube ich bin am meisten fällen von
den
mexikos hier noch schneller ging mit
adecco die ja mein gott vier stück der
kurier 20 meter in einzelfällen aber ist
es schon also wenn man jetzt alle so
macht dann über drei tage dafür aber
soviel stört ist okay am besten eine
linie spritzen und dann direkt zack die
perlen drauf und dann die nächste linie
weil ansonsten die schokolade zu schnell
fest wird
also falls ihr so kurz vor weihnachten
nichts anderes zu tun habt dann könnt
ihr täglich backen aber ich finde ich
schön und der kuchen hält sich halt auch
länger durch diese schoko schicht außen
daher ist es schon schon schönes gebäck
[Musik]
ich bin fertig
zeigt mal eure kunstwerke
war
dein rudolf steck die zunge raus unserem
iran hatten
nikolaus und weihnachtsmann gemacht
schön richtig richtig toll und wollte
jetzt reinbeißen oder nicht ihr müsst
ihr natürlich bisschen auftauen lassen
bevor ihr rein weiß also die waren jetzt
vor der kurz vor der deko gefroren jetzt
ist alles fällt und sie waren jetzt im
kühlschrank ich denke die sind jetzt ein
bisschen aufgetaut
kann beißen wir zusammen ein ok
ich muss sagen es klingt wie magnum wie
in der werbung und
der ist richtig lecker und ich muss
sagen wenn jetzt
zu sagen wir jetzt noch keine kinder mit
essen und ihr so eine erwachsene version
daraus macht die eben gleich nicht so
verspielt und kindlich sind könnt ihr
zum beispiel auch gerne rum dazu geben
oder einen likör oder lieber in die kür
was auch immer ihr möchtet dann probier
ich da einfach gerne austeilt auf jeden
fall mit uns eure
dekorationsideen falls ihr jetzt nicht
unbedingt so gestalten wollt wie wir ich
wünsche euch viel spaß dabei
guten appetit wir machen wir müssen
richtig sauber machen viel spaß beim
verschenken und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]